hi guys welcome back to today I'm doing
a crash course on foundation our
foundation is a CSS responsive framework
that makes every website available on
mobile tablet and desktop devices my
name is shadow and I'm going to be
showing you guys today how to implement
is CSS responsive framework called
foundation now for this tutorial I'm
using specifically foundation version 6
made by ZURB let's get straight into the
crash course gonna go to google or your
browser and you're gonna type in
foundation.com it should bring you to
this website if it doesn't look like
this might have been outdated so we're
gonna go ahead and click download we're
gonna download the complete because it
just gives us everything
look download it should give you a zip
file down here now you're gonna go to
your desktop and you're gonna click
you're gonna right-click go to new
folder and you're gonna name I'm gonna
name this foundation you can name it
whatever you want back to your browser
and go to your your foundation download
file click extract all click browse but
a desktop click Foundation click select
folder and then click extract and what
that does is basically takes all the
files that we just downloaded and put it
into our desktop file called foundation
and we come down here and we read a
little bit about it and how it works and
it down here and it shows sites and
emails you can also do foundation for
emails but for this tutorial we're just
gonna do sites so we're gonna want to do
is you're gonna go over to getting
started then you're gonna click sites
kitchen sink and you should be in this
giant long list called kitchen sink now
kitchen sink is every element available
in foundation all on one page as you see
if you scroll down there's tons of tons
of stuff you can put on to it we're
going to go through all of it we're
going to want to do now is you're going
to want to go down to your editor I'm
using atom in this example
and you're going to want to click open a
project
and we're going to select all on
foundation
it should bring us
okay so what we get is this large HTML
file
pretty long so what we're gonna want to
do is we're going to want to leave
everything out of the body tags keep the
body tags delete everything inside of
the body tags except for the JavaScript
and you should be left with this okay so
what we want to go into do next is we're
going to build some simple form
validation inside of foundation now
we're gonna just start off with some
form tags so we're gonna select that
I'm gonna write form just like that
we're gonna put some JavaScript data
values in here so we're gonna put data
- abide and no validate we're gonna put
a div inside of here
we're gonna give it a class called grid
touch X and grid ash margin - X now
inside of that dip we're gonna put
another div and we're just gonna give it
a class of cell we're gonna make another
div we're gonna give it a class called
alert blur pull out we're gonna give it
a style splay none we're gonna go back
and we're going to add some JavaScript
values data yeah abide - you'll alert
okay so next you're gonna make another
div and you're gonna call it you're
gonna give it a class of grid X and grid
margin X and it's the same thing as this
one up here it's just how foundation
sorts out it's their divs
you're gonna put another dip in here
you're gonna give it a class called cell
small - 12 and we're gonna do next is
inside of this diff you're gonna put a
label and you're gonna put number number
3 wire now you're gonna write an input
tag and set the type to text or keep it
as text and then put a placeholder of
one two three four since we are
validating numbers and we want the user
to know what kind of input the put and
then you're gonna put something called
area - describe describe I set it equal
and inside these or you're gonna put
example help text make sure you
capitalize the last two in camel case
next you're going to put a required
pattern so you're gonna type in required
and then you're gonna put a space and
then pattern and you're gonna set it
equal to number and then you can just
take out this name and value it's not
needed inside of there now next you're
gonna make a span and you're gonna give
it a class of form - err
and inside of this you can basically put
whatever you want for when the user
misspelled something or something so you
can say yo you for something like that
so when there's an error message it will
just give you this this is basically the
error message and after this span make
sure you close out the label
and after that label you can put a
paragraph tag and give it a class of
help text so we're gonna put class help
- text save it I mean you're gonna give
it an ID of example alt text and make
sure you camelcase those and the next
you're gonna put whatever you want
however you want to help the users so
imma put here is how you fill it out and
then just save it it's what whatever
help text you really want to put into it
okay so next you're gonna want to make a
div they're gonna give it the class the
same one as the one up here you can just
copy it and paste save it you're gonna
put a label and you're just going to put
password beep wired
and then after that you're going to put
an input and you're going to put the
type as password make sure the label is
outside on the very end
make sure you add an ID and set it to
password and you can set the placeholder
to whatever you want as long as it looks
like a password so like uh like let's
say if this was a password I mean really
the same thing we did up here with the
area described by so we're just gonna
copy this and paste it down here and
then we're gonna write after it required
and we could take out these name and
values because we don't need them and
after that we're gonna put a span and
add a class to it and in that class
we're gonna call it form air and then
we're just gonna put I'm required make
sure you're span and label and after
that if you want you can invent them and
after the span and label we're gonna put
a paragraph tag we're gonna give it the
class as help text and then we're going
to give them the ID as example help text
camel cased inside of this we're gonna
put enter a pass or go to eat now if you
open it up in your browser the HTML file
you see you get these two input fields
in here now if you're the type in
something other than numbers let's say
AVC and press enter it's gonna say yo
you forgot something and if you go to
this password area and you just press
enter it's gonna say I'm required so it
basically validates your form to make
sure there's an input now these are just
placeholders but other than the
placeholders it's pretty much empty and
you press ENTER and it says I'm required
and if you put letters inside of the
numbers it's gonna say you forgot
something in your form
so that's just some simple form
validation for numbers and passwords you
can always just change it as you see in
the code it's pretty much a pattern up
here and we can even add a comment right
here you just say about error message
/ valid right here and this is basically
what validates it and then down here
is the number valid date and then after
that there's the password validate and
basically what you can do is you can
copy any of these and just change the
classes and stuff you can always check
the foundation website too it'll also
tell you how to change it but these are
just some simple form validation for
foundation okay so up next is the
accordion menu or just the accordion and
so we're just going to add a comment
down here we're just going to call it
you
and gonna tab it down here so basically
what we're gonna first do is put it in
an unordered list and we're gonna put a
class up here we're gonna call it
accordion and then we're gonna put a
data value called data - a core in
inside of here we're gonna put a list
item tag and then we're gonna give it
class name called accordion item is
active and then we're just gonna give it
a javascript value called data 40 an
item after that we're gonna put a link
so we're just gonna type in a an anchor
tag we're gonna give it a class and
we're gonna give it the class called
accordion title we're just gonna call
this one
accordion one and then after that we're
gonna put a div we're gonna give this
one a class called accordion - content
and then we're gonna give it a
JavaScript value called data - tab -
content and then after this we're gonna
put a paragraph tag and we're gonna go
give it a class next we're gonna put a
paragraph tag and we're just gonna say
hello world for this one and then we're
just gonna put a link and we're just
gonna put link in it and it's just going
to be an empty link now if we go to our
website reload we get this little panel
right here but as you see there's only
one so we're gonna go back into our code
and copy and paste it so we get more
accordions
so see we're back in here and we're
gonna copy and paste all of this
actually we're only going to copy and
paste what's inside of the list item
we're just gonna do it three times and
then at the end you're just gonna put
the closing tag from the unordered list
and then if you go back to your code you
see here you can minimize each tab
so it's like an accordion and you can
open them up by going like this
it's pretty coolest so we're gonna
customize it a little bit more so
instead of this being panel one we're
gonna put panel two we're gonna take out
this dummy text
and we're gonna call this one panel
- this one back to panel one this one
panel three we're going to take out all
this dummy text
and now if we go back to it we reload we
get all these
or it's like this and we can customize
it even more changing these and saving
it and then we reload let me see you get
all organized with its content inside of
it so accordion one panel one they're
just empty links
and you can open up each one and it
gives you a new panel now up next are
something called badges badges are an
interesting kind of element inside of
foundation so I'm just gonna show you
what they are so let's just put a
comment saying badges and we're gonna
make a span tag we're gonna give it a
class we're gonna call it primary badge
and inside of that we're just gonna put
the letter A as capitalized so we can
view it and if you go over to your
browser and you click reload you see
down here
down in the bottom left corner of your
screen you should see the letter A and
tied up inside of a little circle
now we can copy this code
make another version of it
instead of primary we can do something
called secondary
secondary badge and then we can just put
it be but go back to the page and reload
you get this
you get this gray badge down here
you
now I've added a a div that has a margin
bottom of 200 pixels just so you guys
can view the badges easily now if we go
down here and make another span or copy
and paste it instead of primary or
secondary we're gonna do warning and
then we're gonna put this one with a c'
save it go to your webpage
and click reload and you'll get a yellow
one with the letter C inside of it
now if you go back to your code make
another one there's also another class
called alert and alert badge and Success
badge and if you reload you see you have
all different colors of badges and the
purpose of a badge is kind of like when
something goes successfully or some sort
of warning it shows up this badge next
to like some words saying your form did
not validate and it's it has a red badge
to it it can signify something about
your form or about something you're
trying to fill out
these are also just great little
decorations but if i zoom out to normal
you can almost barely see them and I
don't know why that is I don't think
it's meant for reading I think I think
it's meant just for the color and for
signifying that something's not
correctly filled out so up next we have
buttons and we're just gonna start off
by putting a comment saying buttons
we're just button we're gonna start off
by obviously making a button and we're
gonna keep the type is button but we're
gonna take away the the name of the
button cuz we don't need the name and
then we're gonna give it a class called
button now if you look at your website
can you reload it you see down here you
get an empty blue box that's because you
have to put text inside of it so we're
just gonna put button and if you go back
and reload you see you have a button
down here
now I'll add that padding back in here
just so that we can get so you can see
it clearly
we reload as you see it's down here now
you can give each button a type of class
that changes the color or look of the
button so for example if we copy this
paste it and put a second or success
button
and you reload it gives you a blue
button if we were to paste it again and
say alert button with a space and reload
it you would get a red one you can also
do the same for sizing so you can do
tiny button and it gives you a tinier
button
or you could do a large button will give
you even bigger button
and you can even do things like expanded
button so if we go to the class and put
expanded button reload you see it takes
up the whole width of the screen you can
also have a small button too so it's in
between the tiny and large button so if
you just put small button and you reload
you get this medium sized button and
these are basically all the buttons
obviously they're not linked to anything
because we need amp put a hyper
reference into here but you can link
these to different things such as exist
such as a success page or an air page
take up the whole bottom of a portfolio
object or you can just have different
sizing buttons and colors they all have
automatic hover and whenever it's like a
green button or a black button it will
turn to white text or black text next
we're gonna do something called call-out
so now the call-outs are like little
messages that show up on your screen
they're not really messages nor more
like sections so I'm going to show you
what they are and how they're useful now
we're gonna just put a comment like
always and we're gonna just call this
call-out and then just indent it here
and then we're gonna make a do and we're
gonna have the class as call-out we're
going to put in h5 and we're just gonna
say hello world and then we're gonna put
a paragraph tag or does it say this is a
call-out we're gonna save it and you
know just for fun we're gonna put a link
and we're just gonna say link now if we
go to our browser you see down here we
have a call-out it's just a simple
little section that we have that says
hello world this is a call-out and a
link which does nothing and but what we
can do with it is we can change it so
let's copy this
and we're gonna set actually
just copy the call-out part not the the
margin we're gonna do call-out warning
and it gives us this yellow color now we
can do this for success and alert too so
if we do
pull out success and call out they alert
and we reload you get the green one and
the red one which are just basically
like like the buttons and the badges
success and warning now there's also a
secondary one that shows the gray if we
call out secondary we save it we reload
you get this grayish kind of one now
another thing too about this is there's
also a primary one where you can set it
back to its default called calm call-out
primary and if you save can you reload
you get back to this blue one there's
the difference between just call out and
call out primary and secondary obviously
alert warning and success are completely
different but you always have to watch
out for these these class changes so in
foundation there's things called closed
boxes or just closed outs but you can
basically do with them is you can add
them to call-outs for example and you
can be able to close out of a call-out
and wipe it from your screen and I'm
going to show you how to do that so what
you're going to want to do is you're
gonna want to add a data value after
your class called data - close
it will then after that you're gonna
want to add a button so just type in
button and you can keep the type as
button and you can take out the name
you're going to add a data value to this
called data close we're going to add an
area label before the data close so area
- label I'm going to set that equal to
you're going to write close alert and
you're going to give it a class called
close button
and save the file after this you're
gonna make a span inside of the first
span tag into play area - hidden and
you're gonna set it equal to true : and
then save the file now you're going to
want to put this span you're going to
copy it
and then you're gonna put it inside of
the clothes I mean you're gonna put it
inside of the button and then you're
gonna save now if you go to your website
now if you check your web browser you
should see this little X over here and
when you click it it just disappears
now when you reload the page obviously
comes back because it's not saved into
your local data or caches but there's a
way you can do that but you can
basically exit out of any call-out you
want just by adding those data variables
and the classes and make sure you do
wrap the variables into the div so make
sure there's one large div around the
whole thing like in here I added a div
so it would close off the call-out make
sure you put a div so you close out the
call-out and the close button and the
span and yeah basically that's how you
add an exit out button or a closed out
tab on any call out okay so up next
we're gonna do a drop-down pane now drop
down pane is basically where you click
the button and it shows a little message
below it these could be used for many
things such as heirs with badges or
panels and it use this as a little help
text so we're gonna I'm gonna show you
how to do this so first we're gonna
scroll down after all the call-outs
we're gonna make a comment all right tab
it in and we're gonna call it drop down
pane
and save it and then first we're gonna
put a button we're gonna leave the type
alone we're just gonna take out the name
so we don't need it we're gonna give it
a class called button so class button
this just gives primary button standards
we're gonna put data
- toggle and set it equal to we're gonna
name it - example - drop-down and now
inside of this button we're just gonna
put drop actually we're just gonna say
toggle drop-down and after this button
we're gonna make a div it's gonna have
the class drop-down - pane we're gonna
give it the ID of example
- drop-down and then we're going to give
it data
- drop-down and then we're just gonna
call this one drop-down hang and if we
go to our website this should be working
and down in the bottom right you should
see this little button saying toggle
drop-down if you click it and scroll
down you get this little text bubble
saying drop-down pane now if we Center
this it works a little easier and if we
add padding so we're gonna do that just
to show for a full example
now we're going to give this
we're gonna put this in tough inside of
the larger div so we're gonna put div
we're gonna copy all of this inside of
here and we're going to just we're not
going to give this a class we're just
going to do inline styling we're going
to do display flex and then we're going
to do just defy ash con tenth Center a
text - align Center
and we're just gonna add margin 15
pixels if we save this this should give
it a nice look to it
so as you see it has pretty good but
we're gonna add some more margin to it
so that it centers more up we're just
gonna say 25 and if you reload it looks
nicer now if you click it you get this
little text below it saying it drop down
pane now if we want to see the full
example we're gonna add about 50 and
then we're just gonna do from margin
we're gonna do a margin bottom that way
we get what we want we reload you click
it says drop down pane and we click the
button again it goes away just like a
help text or an air so up next is
floating classes and we're gonna be
floating buttons to left or right so
first we're gonna add a comment and
we're gonna just say hello buttons we're
gonna put floating buttons and then just
indent it a little and then what you're
gonna do first is just but you're gonna
put button you're gonna take out the
type and you're gonna actually can keep
the type you're gonna take out the name
you're gonna add class as just button
and then you're gonna put a space and
then float - left and then you're gonna
put inside of the button just some text
same flow left and if you go to your
browser you should have a button
floating to the left now as you see down
here you have a button floating to the
left also you don't always have to use
just the normal primary button you can
always go like you know always go a
success button and make it a green
button or even a an alert button so
alert button look left
and then you can just copy this
and let's say we want this to be a
success button and we're just gonna make
a float to the right or just continue
chain chain right to go back to our tab
reload you have a green button floating
on the right and a red button floating
on the left and those are basically the
floating classes for buttons so up niks
are labels and labels are basically
almost like the badges but you can
actually put a word inside of them and
be able to read the word so I'm going to
show you what that is so we're gonna
make a comment and we're just gonna put
labels and then indent so what you're
gonna first want to do is you're gonna
put a span you're gonna give it a class
called primary label and then inside of
that you're gonna put primary label and
then you save it if you go to your
browser as you see at the bottom you see
this little blue thing called primary
label now if we go back and we copy it
and you could put things like success
and just keep pacing it you can do copy
it and you can paste it you can put
warning
you could put alert
and you can even do secondary if you
save it and go view it in your browser
you see in the bottom left you have all
these labels right here and they're not
buttons so you can't really click on
them and expect to go somewhere the more
like the badges where they're just there
to show you like a message of some sort
but like a very small message so such as
success or virus or hello so they're
they're kind of useful but sometimes
they're not so up next we're doing off
canvases and off canvases are those
things you kind of see when you're on
mobile devices so for example you're
trying to look at the menu but you're on
your phone you usually have an off
canvas appear and it's the three little
lines that you click on opens up a side
canvas or an off canvas and also
referred to as off menus or side menus
we're gonna learn how to make one of
those in found eight so first you can
start off with div tags obviously you're
gonna give it a class called off - can
this - wrapper and you're gonna give it
another div and the class is gonna be
off canvas inner off canvas wrapper -
inner and you're gonna save that I'm
gonna give it the data type data off
wrapper after this you're gonna put
another div and you're gonna give this
one a class name of off - Japan s pose
this Shawn
- left you're gonna add an ID hold off
canvas left and then you're gonna add
data off - off - and this
and then after all that we're gonna
leave those divs empty for now after
that they're gonna add a button you're
gonna take out the name like we usually
do
I'm gonna give it a class we're just
gonna put it as the button class with
the primary button we're gonna add data
ash toggle I'm going to set it equal to
off and this left and then we're just
gonna put in here open or we're just
gonna put off and this forgot that the
comments so we're just gonna add that
really quick or just say it off and this
save it now if you go to your browsers
you should see this button down here and
when you click it it gives you this off
canvas kind of look but it has no
content inside of that so we're gonna
add that really quick so over here in
these inner divs all the way into the
middle we're just gonna put an h2 tag
and we're just say hello world and then
we're just gonna put in each for it just
saying Docs or we're just put HTML and
then another h4 the same CSS
just another one I'm called Java Script
and save that reload and we click off
canvas and gives us this little side
menu we could bank we can make these
links too just by adding opening and
closing tags to the very ends copying
and pasting them
and adding placeholders as hashtags save
it you reload and now there are links
and you click on them and it just brings
you back to the top of the page open it
and this is just these are just links
and this is an off-campus menu but when
you minimize it if we inspect and we go
to mobile let's just go to a google
pixel - and we click off canvas it looks
like one of those menus that you would
have for a phone so and this works on
any phone we can go all the way down to
an uh an iPhone 5se and it still works
which are usually the smaller phones so
it's good to know that these still work
on all devices so up next is pack nation
now pack nation is like a type of
navigation that hangs out at the bottom
and you can go through multiple pages
usually at the bottom of product pages
or blog pages you can go through
multiple pages without having to
navigate through the top navigation bar
I'm going to show you how to do that
down here we're just gonna make a
another comment as usual just so we can
divide up our code we're just going to
say pagination bar indent it a little
and then we're gonna start off with an
unordered list give it a class of tag in
nation we're gonna give it a role
instead of equal to navigation and then
we're going to put area - label and then
set it equal to tag in nation with the
capital P inside of this we're gonna put
an list item we're gonna give it a class
called this able inside of this we're
gonna put previous and inside of this a
list item we're gonna put a span tag
we're gonna give it a class called show
- before - SR and then we're just gonna
put Paige in between this fan tag we
could just close off the ends like that
and then after this you're gonna you're
gonna copy this and paste it below and
you're gonna change the class name to
current
actually you're not gonna put any you're
not gonna put anything between those so
you're gonna take out the previous you
just put you are on or on page and then
in between the span and the list item
you're just gonna put one after that
you're gonna put another list item list
item you're just gonna put a list item a
link inside of this you're gonna set it
to just the hashtag is to placeholder
you put area label you set it equal to
page two in between you're gonna put a
to between the anchor tag and then
you're just gonna copy and paste this
and you're just gonna change the numbers
from two to three four you can just take
out this last one we only need to go to
four you shouldn't change this to three
or so next you're gonna add a list item
you're gonna give it a class of ellipse
and you're gonna do it area now she
didn't equal they're gonna just do true
and you're just gonna leave this as that
and you're gonna copy just two of these
and then you're just put in for now
we'll just put uh pages 12 and 13 we're
gonna change this for that after that
you're gonna copy this this item right
here
you're gonna paste it you're gonna set
the area labeled to capital next space
page make sure the page is not
capitalized and then after that instead
of 13 you're just gonna put next and
then you're gonna copy this span right
here
you're gonna paste it after next instead
of putting your on page you're gonna put
page if you reload your web page you
should get this down here that looks
like a little navigation that you would
have for a website and as you see the
disabled class works perfectly with
previous and then you can go on to next
pages and stuff except for we only have
one page so it's not gonna go anywhere
but we're gonna styled it stylize this a
little bit more so you go to your
unordered list we're gonna add a style
tag we're gonna say display flex and
then we're gonna put justify content and
then we're gonna set it to center and if
we go back to our web browser and we
reload it it should be in the middle
just like most webpages would look like
now flexbox does work pretty well with
foundation I haven't found any airs with
it as you can see I easily centered that
in div or that unordered list into the
middle with no problem
so foundation does work pretty well with
Flex box and this is what a pack nation
looks like on a web browser and that's
how you make it in foundation so up next
is progress bars now just a disclaimer
in my opinion bulma's progress bars are
much better
foundations but we're still gonna learn
them anyway just to see the difference
between the two so let's just go ahead
and make them you're gonna go down here
just make a comment and then down here
you can make a div you're gonna give it
a class of primary progress save that
and they're gonna go inside so inside of
this des if you're gonna make another
dip and you're gonna put the class name
at the progress that's meter and then
style with 25% side of this you're gonna
put paragraph tag you need to put 25%
you're gonna give this paragraph tag a
class it's gonna be progress - meter -
text this is gonna be all there is to
your progress bar and now if you check
your browser now if you check your
browser you see you have this progress
bar in here and you can customize it
even more with the warning and success
labels as here all we have to do is copy
it and we just put a warning progress
and we reload it we have a yellow one
and do this the same for alert and we
could do this the same for success and
if we reload you have all these
different colors there is not a
secondary one because the background is
already grey so it'd be kind of useless
you wouldn't be able to tell the
difference between the progress so they
just decided not to have a secondary one
and now the weights you change the the
progress on the bars is you go up to
this with styling and you just change it
to whatever percent you want and then
down here in the paragraph you want to
change it to match that so this primary
progress should now be out fifty percent
change any of these so we've changed
just 65 percent
change this one to 3%
and yeah basically if we reload you have
all different types of widths and stuff
and different colors for different types
of labeling and yeah that's basically it
for progress bars so uh necks are
switches now switches are kind of
pointless without a back end but I'm
still going to show you the front end
and how they're used in foundation
so first we're gonna make a comment
right as always my foundation switch and
then we're gonna save that we're gonna
make a div we're gonna give this a class
called tiny switch we're gonna put an
input we're gonna give this a class of
switch - input and save it we're gonna
give it an ID of tiny switch and then
we're gonna change to type from text to
check box and we're gonna change the
name to example switch and we can take
out the value as well now after that
we're gonna put a label we're gonna add
a class to it and this one's gonna be
called switch - paddle let's save that
and then we're gonna put four small
switch we're gonna put a span inside of
the label
I'm gonna give it a class I'm gonna be
show - four - sr and the inside of this
we're gonna put small portion only we're
gonna capitalize each of these and this
should basically give you a switch now
if you go ahead and check your browser
so in your browser you're gonna see this
little switch down here in it this is
all it does kind of a misleading but it
still looks cool to play with click it a
million times if you like with some
back-end I guess it'd be kind of cool
you can fill it out as a form oh like
yes no yes no now you can also add
different classes so that you can make
them bigger or smaller
so we're basically gonna copy this we're
gonna paste it down here we're going to
change every tiny to small so we're just
gonna go ahead and
take every tiny
we're gonna go small and then save it
and if you reload you have another one
that's slightly bigger than the first
one and we do the same thing and make it
bigger we're just gonna copy this and
we're gonna find everywhere where it
says small
and the way I'm doing this is I'm
holding control while I'm clicking
and you're just going to backspace and
put large
and you're gonna save that you're gonna
reload and you're gonna have a very
large button or switch and this is
basically how switches work in
foundation up next we're gonna make
tables now tables look a little
different in foundation and I'll you'll
see why in a minute
but we're just gonna go ahead and start
making that now so obviously you know
the drill we're just gonna make some
comment so we can keep organized
then and then you're gonna put a table
tag just like that and then T head or
table head and then we're gonna make a
table row now we're gonna make a table
header we're gonna give it a width of
200 we're just gonna name this table
header and then we're gonna do another
table header we're just gonna add no
width to this and just say table header
now we're gonna copy and paste this one
twice we're gonna change this one to 150
or a change
this one the 150 as well now after the
table head we're gonna make a table body
and then we're gonna make a table row
and then table data and inside of this
data we're gonna put just some text some
filler text so we're just gonna say
content goes here and next one we're
just gonna do table data laura miss p.m.
and we're just gonna minimize this down
a little bit
you
and then we could just copy this one
and paste it twice over there and after
that we're gonna copy this and paste it
three more times or two more times as
you see we have a perfectly made table
over here you see the first row goes
gray or a light gray the second one goes
full white and then it's a pattern after
that and basically what we did is we
made one with a certain amount of width
and basically it organizes it like in a
CSS grid so that it goes one large and
in two small ones and this is basically
how a table works in foundation so up
next is the title bar now the title bar
it's very responsive navigation usually
used on mobile and web apps or mobile
web sites when you're designing for
mobile first and usually I have the
little cutout on the side where the
breadcrumbs that you can easily navigate
through and they're very responsive so
I'm going to show you how to make one in
foundation so just gonna make a comment
title bar like that in the dent and then
you're gonna give it a class call it the
title dash bar inside of there you're
gonna make another div and it's gonna be
called title - bar left cuz we're gonna
make it to the left we're gonna put a
button we're gonna leave the type is
button but we can take out the name
we're gonna give it a class we're gonna
call this menu - icon we're gonna put a
span out for this and this is gonna have
a class called title - bar - left and
side up here we're just gonna put
foundation and then after that div
inside of the title bar div but not
inside of the title bar left we're gonna
make another div we're gonna call this
one title - bar - right we're gonna put
a button we're gonna take out the name
we're gonna put a class in here we call
it menu I put a dash in the toy and this
should give you your little title bar
and if you
your browser should have this little
title bar now you want to obviously put
at the top of your webpage so it looks
like a title now I added some margin so
it looks like it's at the top of the
page it's really not it's just it's just
some margin but it looks like it's at
the top of a page and this is basically
what it looks like the pages don't do
anything but you can actually connect
the off canvas to those those to the
menu icons and they can open up side
menus especially if you're on mobile
that can be useful and this is all
responsive if I were to go like this
it's all responsive there's not much to
respond about but it's still responsive
if you have actual navigations inside of
this black bar right here it becomes
responsive and yeah that's basically how
you make a navigation slash title bar in
foundation so up next is a tool tip and
a tool tip is like you'll see them in
wikipedia a lot and it kind of gives you
a general definition of a word that the
user might not quite understand right
away so where I'm going to show you how
to do that now we're just gonna make a
comment I'm gonna call this tool tip and
we're gonna make a paragraph tag because
it is a sentence and we're just gonna
put the we're going to space it but we
take out that space now inside of this
paragraph tag we're gonna put a span now
the span is gonna have a data type
called data - too old - and then it's
gonna have area that has pop we're going
to set that equal to true we're gonna
set a class to has - tip now we're gonna
say data
- disabled - hover we're going to set
that equal to full and then we're gonna
put tab index we're going to set tab
index equal to 1 and then we're gonna
put title and see word for a beetle
and then this is just another word for a
beetle I just copied and pasted it and
then this is just some filler text I
found well we're just gonna do
Laurent this VM we're gonna save that
and if you go into your browser and you
reload you see down here you get the
sentence and oops make sure you put a
space after the title
not a space after the definition word if
you reload you get this and when you
hover over it says fancy word for a
beetle and it's just a basic definition
of what it is you'll see these alot in
Wikipedia you can add these to your Docs
on your website or whatever and that's
how it works in foundation so up next is
something called HTML templates in
foundation now nation has their own set
of templates they have a total of eight
if you go to a foundation or comm slash
templates IHT ml you'll find these HTML
templates now there's a total of eight
and you could download any of them or
you can just watch the demo they have
news magazines real estate ecommerce
blogs portfolios and product pages and a
few more these are very helpful if
you're just trying to create a portfolio
for your business or for getting a job
and you don't have too much experience
and you just need something to get out
there with today we're just gonna do the
portfolio so you're gonna click see demo
and as you see this is what the
portfolio looks like or the template and
if we right click and click view page
source there's all this code right here
we're gonna click ctrl a ctrl C so
basically what we're gonna do is we're
gonna click ctrl a and ctrl v and you're
gonna save it now the first thing you're
gonna notice is everything is in one
straight line and nothing is organized
like we are organizing it earlier and
that's okay you just need an atom
package or a package to go along with
your code there's gonna be a link in the
description it's an atom package called
atom beautify and this organizes your
code just like we were doing with all
the indentations and white space now you
can install this package just by
clicking install and open with atom and
it should install like that
if not you can install using NPM or the
APM command line and just install it
that way but it's so much easier if you
just click the install here but once
you've installed this you should be able
to go to your code and click packages
atom beautify and then click beautify
what this does is it organizes all the
code automatically with all of its
indentations and stuff now if you go to
your file folder and you click your text
or
your document you should find this as
your document not the link anymore and
here's where we will reload and edit our
website so we can just minimize out of
this minimize out of that and the first
things we can change is the title we're
gonna change this to portfolio o or o yo
save we can leave all these links alone
you
we can leave all these script tags alone
as you see it just does done
functionality
and you see off-campus position left
reveal for large this is what the off
canvas looks like in this website but
there's not a button to open it so it's
just always open so we're gonna edit
this off canvas first the height is a
hundred percent and then down here we're
just gonna change just to Liam Stockton
save that and then this is a little bio
it looks like right yeah it's a little
bio so I'm a lot of copy and paste a bio
from my portfolio so this is my
portfolio and we're just gonna go to
about and I'm gonna just copy this and
then I don't need that anymore then
we're gonna go down here I'm gonna paste
it into this paragraph tag and if we
save it reload I have my own about down
here now you can obviously write your
own and you probably should and just
change the span below to my own stock
then save that
then down here there is a call out all
out primary what this call out is is
this thing up here and they set the
width so that it takes up the entire
heading basically and so we're going to
change this
we're going to just change this to
expand
expand your creativity and it's just
gonna have some words down here we're
just gonna change this text to something
whatever you really want it's gonna come
up here so you just kind of choose what
you want to say up here I'm gonna just
write some stuff so I wrote this is just
little phrase right here and if we go
ahead and reload you see we get this
over here and now we need to move on to
the pictures so I pulled an image from
my my personal images and I'm gonna just
paste it into here
and we're gonna rename this to me and
it's a JPEG file so down in or we're
gonna go back up to the image instead of
this right here we're just gonna do me
dot jpg and if we reload there's a
picture of me up here now now if as far
these projects go we need to find images
for them so over here are basically
projects now of course you're not going
to have like twelve projects as it's
shown here but you're gonna at least
have at least three or four good ones so
we're going to take out some of these
so if we go down here we're gonna look
for it
there's all these cells so we can take
out the first one two three four five
six I'll just take out the first six and
save it we could take out two more
because it kind of looks weird actually
no we're just gonna copy and paste these
two paste them back because we need them
if we reload you should have only eight
and what we're gonna do is we're going
to fill in these projects
so we're just gonna put
we're just going to put portfolio as a
project and then
we're going to make it a link
but portfolios one project we're going
to make this one javascript book worker
that's another project
and we just replace this pasting and
we're gonna put this one as let's just
say personal website or we're gonna do a
personal blog and we're gonna say that
as a website
and these are just different projects
than filling in us obviously you can
come up with your own projects these are
just things that I've done
javascript I'll do it
javascript calculator
and we're just gonna put one here we're
just going to put Python keylogger
we need three more or press plug-ins
actually we need to make this link so
we're gonna do wordpress plug-ins down
here we're just gonna put the day yes
projects and down here we're just gonna
do you dot dash projects and fleet
reload you see we have oops this one is
not a link make sure you make them all
links because you want to link to your
project obviously so we're just gonna do
this reload and you see they're all
links they don't go anywhere you can put
your own link so I'm gonna just lengthy
so I've linked some of my personal
projects in here so if we click
portfolio you get to my portfolio book
JavaScript bookmarker you get to all my
projects now what we need to do is add
pictures or thumbnails so that they want
to click on them so this is where we go
to Google Images
we need to search for port folio we need
it so we're just search for a portfolio
and then end tools we're gonna click
size and then exactly 5:55 550 because
that's what's over in here and it even
tells you the pixel size so I found this
image it's not really an image of a
portfolio but it's gonna work for now
since it's just a stock image so we're
gonna right click and click copy image
address and then we're gonna put it in
for each of these placeholder pictures
I'm just gonna paste it in and you can
even do the control version and just
taste it in like that you do it however
you want it's just how you paste it in
and replace the thumbnail pictures with
this link that we have and forego over
and we reload you see we have a bunch of
phones and this doesn't look very nice
so we're gonna add some variety to it
so we're just gonna keep finding random
images and we're just gonna keep popping
image address and replacing them with
different thumbnails all images will be
in the link in the description I'm just
finding random images and looking copy
image address and just pasting them in
that way it doesn't all look the same we
can get some variety to our portfolio
as you see if I reload okay so once
you're done copying all these images and
finding them you should have a variety
like this now if you want to find these
images you can find them in the
description I found most of them from
just Google Images so it's not that hard
to find but do remember that you have to
cite and credit each of these authors
they're not you can't just take these
images you can always put it down in
your footer somewhere but just make sure
you credit these people who took the
pictures or made the pictures just so
you don't get copyrighted claimed or
even sued okay so after this you're
gonna look at this contact me and you're
gonna want to change the text obviously
because it's just dummy text we're gonna
go ahead and change the text so it says
contact me and then we're gonna change
out this text so we're just gonna say
contact me through my social media or
through the forum
I will try I will be spawned within 72
hour or we're just gonna say uh 24 hours
so I just put some text contact me
through social media or through the
forum I'll try my best to respond within
24 hours and now we now we just need to
check this so change this social media
so but we're not gonna use dribble we're
just gonna do YouTube Instagram and
where they do Twitter I'm I just paste
in these links and Instagram save that
we go back and we reload you see we have
each of these and if you click on them
they lead to your social media in this
case my youtube channel this form does
not work obviously you need to set up
some back-end there is a way you can
plug in MailChimp into foundations into
Foundation's
back-end but and for this tutorial we're
just doing front-end so we're not going
to do that but we're going to go ahead
and look at the form and you can change
the placeholder so it says type here are
we going to say message here
if we go back and reload instead of a
whole lot designer it's going to say
message here
now we have a simple portfolio made in
foundation right here and it looks
pretty good and it's pretty good for our
starter portfolio even if you don't have
much experience with foundation or with
any of these you still can make a pretty
good portfolio using an HTML template in
foundation you're probably wondering
great I can build a website with a
template I know all the factors of
foundation and all of its responsiveness
but how do I build a website from
scratch and that's exactly what we're
gonna do right now so right now we're
gonna build a website from scratch so
completely no templates no no copy and
pasting all just pure code so we're
gonna open up a new tab and dock in Adam
and we're gonna open the project as
foundation we're just gonna open up our
foundation
and then we're just gonna exit out of
all of these tabs and we're gonna keep
this untitled tab right here we're gonna
press ctrl shift s and then we're going
to name this one port folio dot HTML
we're gonna save that and then we're
gonna make ctrl n and then we're gonna
put ctrl shift s I'm gonna name this one
style dot CSS this is gonna be our new
folders for this new website we're gonna
make we're gonna keep the old folders
just so we can refer back to other
elements of foundation if we ever need
to so what we're gonna do first we're
just gonna type in some basic HTML just
type in the words HTML should shortcut
to just this nice ten lines of code will
give you just the the head title body
and closing and opening HTML tags we're
gonna give HTML class called called no -
j/s we're gonna add some more meta tags
so we're just gonna go meta oops meta
tag then we're gonna set and we're going
to set HTTP equivalent set at the x
equals UA and - comm compatible and then
we're gonna set content ie equals edge
say that and after that we're gonna add
another meta tag it's name is going to
be view or viewport like that and then
we're going to set content to width
equals device width and we're gonna add
a comma we're gonna set initial scale
equal to 1.0 and that should be it for
that meta tag and now we're going to
give it a title we're going to call this
portfolio
save that and now we're gonna link in
our links so we're gonna just put link
tags gonna keep style sheet and we're
gonna put in TSS flash foundation dot
CSS after that we're putting a link and
it's gonna be the same thing except for
it's gonna be CSS slash app CSS that way
it has CSS for mobile too after that
we're gonna link our style sheet that's
up here right now
so we're just to put in link and then
it's gonna be just style dot CSS cuz we
didn't put in any folders as you see
here it's out right here in the open
it's not in any folders so that should
set up our head part now we're gonna go
into the actual code for the body so
we're gonna start off with a div I'm
gonna call it title bar and we're gonna
add another div we're gonna give it a
class of title bar left so title are
left cuz we're gonna have a title bar on
the Left we're gonna add another div and
the class is gonna be off canvas and
then position left so we're gonna we're
basically making a a off canvas menu
kind of thing so that when you're on
mobile it can work for off canvas as
well and then we're gonna add an ID not
an idea and I be be equal to off can
this left and then we're gonna add a
data off canvas like that now inside of
here we're gonna add an unloaded list
we're gonna give this our list a class
and it's gonna be submenu gonna be sub
menu menu and then we're too cool so
it's a vertical menu and then it's gonna
have data data submenu now we're going
to add a list item and inside of these
list items are going to be links
so we're gonna copy this now we're going
to paste it five times or four times and
you should have five linked menus now
you're just gonna put home skills
projects about and then contact so we
can navigate through them later we're
just gonna put home ills projects
get out and contact and this we're gonna
put IDs in these sections down further
into the website so we can navigate to
them when we do get there but we're not
there just yet
so after this unrealistic Adil and
inside of here we're gonna put a button
and where you can just take out the or
we don't have to take out any of this
we're gonna put data - the toggled and
then it's gonna equal off and this left
and we don't need the div in this class
right here so we're gonna take that out
just to organize it and we're gonna give
this a class not going class of menu -
icon then we don't need this type or
actually no we don't need this name
after that we're gonna put a span it's
gonna have a class of title our title
we're going to put portfolio inside of
there so inside of the body we're gonna
we're gonna put a div and we're gonna
and inside of this dip we're gonna give
it an ID of home and this is what I was
talking about up here so when you click
the home it's gonna lead you down to
this div and then we're gonna give it a
class of hero - section and hero -
section is not in foundation so we're
gonna add our own personal CSS that's
why we meet the file earlier but we'll
get to that in a second
inside of here we're gonna put another
div and we're gonna put the class's hero
- section - text and then we're gonna
put each one and we're gonna put your
name or in this case my name then we're
gonna do an h5 I'm gonna do front and
web developer now obviously you can add
this to whatever you do this is just for
the tutorial and so what we need to do
now is we need to stylize this so you're
gonna go up and click on your CSS file
it's not there you can click this little
arrow and click style that CSS and it'll
bring you there so what we're gonna do
first we're gonna do here
we're gonna euro - section I'll go like
that now before I start typing realize
that it may seem like a lot of CSS but
it's ten times shorter if you were doing
it without foundation so just have that
in mind gonna do background and then
your L parentheses and I'm a copy and
paste that image URL I found earlier the
link will be in the description
obviously we're going to put parentheses
and just paste it in and then at the
very end we're going to put 50%
no-repeat put a semicolon and press
Enter I'm gonna do background size and
then copy I'm gonna do ie 96 BH which is
a vertical horizontal is what that means
and then text align Center and then
we're gonna do some web kits for the
Internet Explorer users display they do
- web kit - flex you're gonna do display
and then I'm s - flex box you make sure
you put a dash before that and then
after this we're just gonna do normal
display flex and then after that you can
put WebKit - aligned - items and you can
just put Center then we're going to tab
and put MS - flex - align Center and
then we're just gonna do normal line
items Center make sure you put
semicolons after all of this and after
this we're gonna put we're going to go
back from our indentation put WebKit -
defy - content and then we're just put
Center and then after that we're going
to tap and put - MS - flex - pack
Center after that we're just gonna do
justify content center and what this
code basically does all these web kits
and stuff are basically so that other
users can use them as well sometimes it
doesn't work on all computers but the
web kits make sure that it does work on
computers that use Internet Explorer
windows edge or Microsoft edge even
sometimes web browsers like that are a
little bit more complicated so WebKit's
tend to help with that and after this
we're just gonna put you row as section
and then we're just gonna add the second
class hero - section - text and this
puts it in a hierarchy so that only text
inside that the hero section will work
and then we're just gonna add brackets
and we're gonna have the color do Fe Fe
and semicolon I'm gonna text - shadow
one pixel one pixel to pixel and then we
add a color to it as zero A zero A zero
A
semi-cool and this is all the CSS we're
gonna need for right now so we can go
back to our HTML now before we open it
in the browser we need to come down here
and add our JavaScript so we're gonna go
in the body we're just gonna kind of
indent so we're gonna make a script tag
and we're just gonna take out this break
right here we're gonna put it as J s
slash bend or slash jQuery yes and we're
just gonna copy this paste it three more
times
should have four script tags just change
this to what input change this to
foundation juice and this one too op je
s and now it should work if we go ahead
and check our browser you should get
this looking right here now this is a
pretty good home page you have our own
custom made hero section our little
welcome and if you come up here to the
navigation you get this side menu right
here with all of the basically
navigation of the website and if you
click home not gonna bring this anywhere
because this is already home so but that
would work if we were to scroll down and
have more parts of the website that
would work now after this we're going to
add another div we're gonna give it an
ID of skills which we will use later for
the navigation and we're going to give
it a class of skills I'm going to add an
h2 with the style of text at line s and
then colon Center semicolon inside of
here we're gonna put skills after this
we're going to add an h3 called HTML and
after this we're gonna add some progress
bars and that's gonna show how well we
know the skill for this portfolio and
add a div we're gonna give this class a
and it's gonna have primary progress as
its class and then role is going to be
progress bar
tab index equals zero
now we're gonna set area ash value now
equal to or we're gonna take out this -
and set it equal to zero actually we're
going to set it equal to 25 and we're
gonna copy this
you
and we're going to paste it instead of
now we're gonna put min and we're going
to set it to zero we're going to set
we're going to paste it again instead up
now we're going to put text we're going
to set it equal to 25% we're going to
paste it again we're going to set max as
instead of now and we're going to set it
to 100 and then we're gonna take this
back and we're gonna press Enter so
there's room inside of this div all
right another do it's gonna be called
progress - meter and then style we're
gonna set width to with to 90% and then
paragraph tag set class equal to
progress
- meter - text and this should give us
one of the progress bars if we check our
browser they reload we scroll down we
see we get this little progress bar down
here and then we're gonna make a div up
here after skills and call it skills -
inner and we're gonna copy the progress
bar and everything with that inside of
here and then we're gonna go into our
CSS tab and stylize this skills thing so
we're just gonna go skills curly bracket
and then we're going to set height to 35
th and then text-align:center
and then background or set it we're
going to set it to 4 D 5 7 6 8 and then
put a semicolon and then we're going to
set the skills inner class
- width of 50 percent and then margin
left 25% and then padding-bottom five
pixels and what this basically does is
it takes the normal hero section it
makes it smaller and then everything
inside of it is going to be centered in
the middle inside of a smaller box you
go to your browser and reload you should
see it like so that this is like all in
one section and then the the progress
bars are in a smaller section inside of
it that's what the skills inner class is
for so now we can basically copy and
paste everything from the h3 HTML tags
down to the end of the primary progress
so we're just gonna copy this and paste
it three times like that and I'm gonna
change this to css3 and this one to draw
a script es6 and then if you want you
can change probably should change each
of these so let's say each our CSS is
only 85% and we change the text down
here so 85% and then JavaScript let's
say it's only 75% or just change these
values down here if you go to your
browser and you reload you should have
three more progress bars with different
values in them or the values you set to
it so here it shows that HTML is no 90
percent and I know it's css3 85 percent
of the way and JavaScript es 6 about 75
percent of the way now this is just
hypothetical for this portfolio but you
can change these values to whatever
you'd like
so after all these divs we're gonna put
a div we're gonna give it a class of
projects and then we're gonna give it an
ID of projects
I'll go down here and save that and
inside of here we're gonna give it a div
and a class called project - the box and
then we're gonna do a a tack or an
anchor tag inside of the anchor tag
you're gonna do an image now I found
this image offline if you want it it's
down in the description along with
everything else and so I just copied the
image address and I pasted it and now
we're going to add some alt text of Port
olio
after that you're gonna put in an h2 tag
and you set this style
- text - align Center and then we're
just gonna put project as Stiller we're
gonna do we're just gonna do a personal
blog and then after this we're gonna
copy this project box two more times
we're going to change the text from a
personal blog to Java Script bookmarker
and then we're just going to do
portfolio
because I have a second portfolio and if
we go ahead and check our browser so
before we check the browser we're gonna
go to our style dot CSS and we're gonna
make a projects and project project box
and we're gonna style these so for this
one we're going to display flex make
sure it's a semicolon and we're going to
justify content into this Center I'm
gonna do flex direction and we're gonna
do row and then flex wrap in order to
wrap that way if the browser gets
smaller it will wrap and make it into a
column instead of row and then we're
just gonna set the height to 100% and
down in the project box we're gonna do
margin 15 pixels we're going to do with
150 pixels and height 150 pixels I do
border we're gonna do border radius 25
pixels and then background color is
going to be black make sure you set this
project box to image I forgot about that
so the styling won't work correctly
without the image that's just targeting
the image part of the box we're gonna go
ahead and change javascript bookmarker
cuz it's kind of a long title and we're
just gonna put j/s book marker and
reload and you should have it looking
like this
now you can obviously switch out the
pictures I just you know I just used the
same one for all three just for
convenience you should probably change
each one of these to your own pictures
of your actual project but for now this
is good after this we're going to add a
div and we're gonna call it we're gonna
give it a class of about and we're going
to give it an ID of about and then we're
gonna put a dip inside of it call it and
give it a class up about box I'm gonna
put an h2 tag in here call it about and
then a paragraph tag and then I'm a copy
and paste my about from
earlier so I'm gonna just paste that in
here and then go back and now we're
gonna go into the styling and we're
gonna add a class of about and a bout
box just set the height to 35 VH not 25
35 and I'm gonna set text align Center
set the background color for the
background color we're just gonna use
the same color we did for skills we're
just gonna paste it down here and
semicolon we're gonna display flex I'm
gonna align items and then into the
center and then we're gonna go down to
the about box I'm gonna give it a
background color we're gonna set it to
5e or $7.99 semicolon and then order
radius 25 pixels and then height of 20
VH makes your semicolon and then with
it's gonna be 50% and then we're gonna
margin left about 25 pixels or percent
and just add a little bit of a padding
bottom of five pixels change this for 70
to 74 I messed up there it will give you
purple if you type in 4/7 so make sure
it's 74 you should get this blue color
if you reload like this and it gives you
a nice soft kind of grayish blue color
that kind of looks nice on the eyes and
also matches these pictures which I did
not plan if you don't like the color
scheme you can always change it there
wasn't too much designing going into
this website it was mostly just a test
every foundation function now one more
theme we're just gonna add another about
box so about - box comma paragraph tag
and we're just gonna set the padding on
this for 5 pixels you go back to your
browser and you reload you see it just
gives a nice padding to the the text of
the so you can read it so after this
we're gonna give it another div we're
going to add the class to contact we're
going to give it an ID of contact it's
just going to be an h2 of contact
I just put user at domain for the email
this is gonna be email just because I'm
not gonna put my actual email but you
guys should put your actual email you
want your employer to contact you also
you don't have to put a email sometimes
I might get confusing it might annoyed
the user and then we're just gonna put
paragraph and we're gonna put a phone
number so I'm just putting some random
numbers so actually we're just gonna go
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 like that I don't
know if that's a real phone number I
wouldn't find out and after this we're
gonna go to our style and we're gonna
add a class of contact I'm gonna set a
background color to a hashtag 0 0 6 EAD
and I'm going to set a height of 20 VH
and then text-align:center and then
after that if you check your browser and
you reload you should have this little
blue thing down here contact and then
email and phone number and obviously
style is that easier this is just like
looking like kind of a call-out kind of
after your body and you're gonna type in
a footer tag now we're gonna just make a
quick little footer just for convenience
and it's just gonna say shadow tech I
copied and pasted a copyright sign
offline and you can just save that I'm
gonna go back to your style and you're
just gonna add footer and then you're
just gonna do text-align:center and then
just set a background color and for
convenience just grey and after that if
you check your website you should have a
fully completed simple portfolio that
was made completely from scratch
completely from foundation and it was
only in about 80 lines of CSS and around
roughly 92 lines of HTML which is very
small for a portfolio or HTML template
was way more than that and this was this
is a lot more than the template as well
so you get more for less basically so
more content for less lines of code for
both portfolio and CSS so now that
you've built your website and foundation
there's a few more things that I think
you guys should check out because
they're kind of cool and it might be
useful so if you go to foundation's
website and you click getting started
and then you click sites you see you get
this little page here and whoa this is
where we found the HTML templates and
there's some other things called
building blocks now as it may seem you
can literally click see code and add
this to your to your website and you can
basically give ratings
based off of you know like what you
would be rating it on basically like you
can copy this code click copy copy and
copy and just paste each one in and
you'd have to add your own JavaScript
through a script tag inside of your
website but that shouldn't be much of a
problem and it basically gives you all
the code for the what it the building
block is so in this case it's a star
rating block and these are created by
other people as you see this person made
this but
you can have your own profiles I guess
but if you go back there's different
things so you can go to navigation
you know these cool little navigations
that people have made in foundation
status
you can add status alerts and graphs and
stuff you can also do control you can
see social icons there's a lot of social
buttons look at the social buttons easy
so you can literally copy which parts
you want so it finally wanted Facebook
Twitter and YouTube and Instagram I
would just copy these and then there's
copy all this because if you want to add
more you can add more basically you take
out which links you want out and you can
link in your own social media and inside
of these hashtags
there's also mobile dashboards
and instead of making our own hero
you've could have we could have gone
here and just clicked fullscreen hero
and copy this code down here and could
have done it that way
but we decided to make it our own since
we were creating our own website from
scratch but if you do want to make
another hero you can just come in here
to the building blocks and find
fullscreen hero and just edit it that
way
go back
we go back all the way to where it says
HTML templates you're gonna click
resources and down here there's all
sorts of add-ons for angular and for
text editors and WordPress all these
back-end stuff and this is where we
would connect the backend with like our
buttons and stuff where is it down here
with Django your dotnet and uh looks
like other back-end stuff like flask for
Python PHP ass foundation anyway up here
you can see there's a icon fonts which
is just some like random stuff I guess
you can put into your website SVG icons
oh so like social media icons and if you
click getting started this is where we
downloaded you can click kitchen sink
and obviously go through kitchen sink
you click home it gives you like a
description of how a foundation works so
50% code reduction so half the size of
foundation 5 this is foundation 6 so
they've upgraded it and if you keep
scrolling through you can read all about
their development and how foundation is
apparently the best front-end framework
that's responsive in the world is what
they claim so throughout this entire
course or crash course
we've learned a lot and let's go over
what we have learned so we went through
all of kitchen sink which gave us every
element of foundation all-in-one let's
say document and we save that website
just as foundation after that we went on
to HTML templates and we basically
learned how foundation is structured
using one of their templates and we
edited the template so that it looks
like our personal portfolio and then
after that we basically made our own
portfolio from scratch and we made it so
that we coded the entire thing we
basically code in the entire portfolio
from scratch not using any templates or
anything just using foundation and it
gave us a 50% code reduction from the
normal portfolio without foundation so
basically um that's all for foundation I
know this was a kind of a long crash
course especially just for foundation
but I made sure that you guys got all
the content of foundation so don't
forget to leave a like
down below it helps a lot and calm it
down if you have any questions if I left
something now I can I'd be happy to help
down in the comment section don't forget
to subscribe and read the bail the
social media is above me go ahead and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram make
sure you subscribe to my youtube channel
and follow me on github all links are
down in the description all the image
URLs the HTML templates foundation's
website and you can even view the
portfolio that I made in this tutorial
on my github and yeah don't forget to
expand your creativity